[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
la crisis climática tiene graves
consecuencias humanitarias millones en
el mundo deben desplazarse de sus
hogares en busca de entornos seguros
lejos de lluvias inundaciones o sequías
el observatorio de desplazamiento
interno Calcula que en 2021 unas 23
millones de personas se movilizaron a
causa de fenómenos meteorológicos África
es uno de los continentes más afectados
somalia enfrenta una hambruna de
magnitudes que no se veían desde hace
medio siglo una situación consecuencia
de la sequías extremas lo que ha
generado un nexodo interno masivo de
casi un millón de somalíes El informes
de Marina sardina
este gesto es un privilegio para
millones de somalíes Y es que más de 4,3
millones de personas se encuentran en
situación de inseguridad alimentaria
consecuencia de la sequías extremas que
están desplazando a miles de personas
puedes imaginar a alguien que ha perdido
su ganado y ha tenido que marcharse
todos nos hemos visto afectados por la
sequía antes en la sequía de 2017 me
quedaron algunos animales Pero esta vez
lo hemos perdido todo solo me quedan
tres cabras
la emergencia climática golpea con más
dureza a los países del sur global con
fenómenos extremos como la sequía y sus
secuelas los somalíes están perdiendo
sus animales los mismos que les dan de
comer generando un desplazamiento
interno en busca de ayuda humanitaria
perdí 10 vacas y un burro por la sequía
cuando dejé mi casa llegué a baidoa fue
un largo viaje tuvimos que parar varias
veces en el camino caminamos hasta
burkaba y luego conseguimos transporte
hasta bairoa la agencia de la ONU para
los refugiados acnur señala que al menos
un millón de personas han dejado sus
hogares en 2022 la mayoría tiene pocas
posibilidades de regresar a sus
territorios abocados a vivir en
condiciones precarias en zonas urbanas o
en abarrotados campamentos humanitarios
el hambre no espera por los recursos a
las personas sin hogar no pueden esperar
por los recursos las personas que no
tienen una letrina o una clínica a la
que enviara a sus hijos no pueden
esperar a recibir recursos es muy
urgente se necesita ahora
Kenia acogido a más de 20.000 soles en
lo que va de año desplazados por la
sequía Pese a que el país también está
sufriendo las consecuencias de la crisis
climática este ganadero keniano pide
ayuda inmediatas a las autoridades tras
perderlo todo no podemos alimentar a
nuestros hijos a nuestro ganado no
tenemos nada ya no podemos pagar las
tasas escolares porque dependemos del
ganado nuestros hijos son enviados a
casa todos los días por falta de cuotas
escolares sin embargo dependemos del
ganado que muera diario son varias Las
Naciones del cuerno de África en riesgo
por la sequías extremas desde yuty hasta
Etiopía que dejarán miles de personas
desplazadas en busca de una vida digna y
un sustento de vida para sus familias
Nigeria sufre las peores inundaciones en
décadas más de un millón de nigerianos
tuvieron que desplazarse internamente
después de que sus hogares quedarán
completamente arrasados por las lluvias
torrenciales miles han perdido su único
sustento de vida poco antes de iniciar
la temporada de cosechas
aldeas sumergidas cultivos completamente
anegados por el agua las peores
inundaciones en décadas en Nigeria
anticipan una catástrofe humanitaria
miles de nigerianos lo han perdido todo
como Este joven agricultor
esto era nuestro hospital como pueden
verlo está completamente inundado esta
era nuestra escuela está bajo el agua
ahora Todo está bajo el agua
lo que antes eran trochas Ahora son
peligrosos Ríos por las que muchas
familias huyen cargando las pocas
pertenencias que pudieron salvar del
agua otros lo hacen en abarrotados botes
en el recorrido decenas de vehículos
varados y transportistas que ven como se
pierden sus mercancías
conseguimos pasar por balleza pero al
llegar aquí ahora no pudimos volver a
pasar porque la carretera se cortó en
dos vemos muchos camiones cisterna
muchos motores que quieren pasar pero no
hay manera así que estamos aquí desde
hace una semana y un día
que han logrado escapar sobreviven en
improvisados campamentos informales
entre mosquitos y lafinamiento
Dios hizo su propio camino me entrego
con éxito en mi camino de regreso y veo
que la inundación ha llegado a mi casa
no hay ningún lugar en el que
permanecerá ahora me muevo hacia el
campamento donde la gente se está
quedando pero no es la forma en la que
vivíamos en nuestras casas no es la
forma de vida
las lluvias torrenciales son frecuentes
en esta temporada en el país africano
pero este año la ferocidad de las
lluvias deja más de 600 muertos y casi
1,5 millones de desplazados internos
según las cifras del gobierno y mientras
la temporada de cosecha se acerca las
afectaciones en los cultivos son
millonarias y pronostican una carestía
de los alimentos así como la pérdida del
sustento de muchas familias dedicadas a
la agricultura todo es muy caro para
nosotros incluso conseguir alimentos
para comer no es tan fácil los expertos
atribuyen el cambio climático las
secuelas de estos fenómenos
meteorológicos adversos pero también a
la negligencia de los gobiernos y a la
falta de infraestructuras para paliar
los daños las predicciones sobre los
desplazamientos a causa del clima son
igual de inciertas a los fenómenos
meteorológicos y su impacto por eso es
difícil prever y atender a las
poblaciones vulnerables afectadas por la
crisis climática
y el dato de migración de la semana
unas 103 millones de personas dejaron
sus hogares Durante los primeros seis
meses de 2022 huyeron por persecución
violaciones a los derechos humanos y
conflictos un 15% más que en 2021
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en francés 24
y France 24.com
[Música]